hey everyone davolo here and in today's
Banger we are diving back into chainsaw
man and going over the full life or at
least all of the info that we have about
the true chainsaw man better known to us
is just pachita and his journey
throughout the series so obviously like
massive spoiler warning to anyone who
doesn't want to know the overall outcome
of part one so far so if you are new
around here as well and want to see
other videos just like this then make
sure you hit that subscribe button and
also be sure to leave a like on the
video as really helps out with pushing
my content to a bunch of new amazing
people plus you know a whole bunch of
like chainsaw man videos throughout the
community recently have been getting age
restricted so just you know like viewer
discretion is advised but this does also
follow YouTube's guidelines I'm not here
to sensationalize the brutality of this
story instead I'm trying to bring you
know light to the amazing writing that
tatsuki Fujimoto actually has but anyway
enough of that let's get into the story
so this here with our teddy bear pochita
isn't going to be as straightforward as
my normal videos where I'll explain arcs
and all because the series is pretty
much through dingy's point of view the
entire time much of potato's past is
shredding a mystery with the little
information throughout the first 80 of
the story being provided by makima and
the other Devils our melon loving boy
annihilates along the way so before the
series even began and something that
like we don't actually know for a while
but actually see when denji first meets
him Bushido was stuck in a hugely
outnumbered fight and after disappearing
from this battle with like some other
people in the series that I'll get to in
a second Vegeta is reduced to like this
near-death state or like Marky McCalls
of this near-death stay and in the state
he appears to be like a small orange
doggo like Devil will they change their
appendage protruding from the center of
his head almost like a nose and that's
kind of like who we come to know him as
throughout the story before he was like
reduced back to this form though he was
this freaking mass of bulked up
humanoid-like Devil with four arms that
had these long ass swords protruding
from each of them with another chainsaw
coming from the front of his head
similar to dingy's hybrid form so like
think of this every time I'm referring
to pachita in the past instead of like
what dingy looks like obviously Vegeta I
guess ever since chainsaws were invented
or maybe even eternity it's not really
told when he came to to existence but he
was known as the chainsaw man in Hell
the source of his fear stemmed from the
series Breaking unique ability of his
which races Devils completely from
existence and the memory of everyone and
everything by simply munching him back
Devils killed by the true chainsaw man
cannot continue The Reincarnation cycle
which for anyone who doesn't actually
know what the devil reincarnation cycle
is pretty much when the devil dies on
Earth their returns to hell and then
when they die in hell they come back to
earth until obviously pachita shows up
and he's like nah bro time for a meal
but there is an extremely simplified
version of it obviously this makes
chainsaw a massive threat to devil kind
and earn him the moniker of the devil
that Devils fear most or the hero of
Hell depending which side you're on this
infamy may put heat of the target of
many Devils who try killing him multiple
times but he always found a way to come
back and fight again his power was
subject to worship for some making
student Devils follow him like beam and
the object of fear for others who ran
away trying to escape him this
eventually culminated in a battle
between him the four horsemen and weapon
devils in which he was barely wounded
and according to markima reduced to a
completely near-death form at the height
of the battle against makima and The
Four Horsemen pachita vanished then was
somehow found on Earth by dingy after
what happened at dinchy's father's grave
pachita who can't communicate and can
only seemingly bark like a pop saw that
dingy and an act of empathy offered him
his blood so that he could recover from
his wounds but only on the condition
that they too would become future
Partners throughout the few years that
they spent together from the time that
dingy was a child to like the current
time period pachita would live alongside
him and his lihi shid listening to dingy
and all of his worries all of his wishes
the food he wanted to eat and pretty
much just everything the toad didn't
have in life while at the same time
assisting him in Devil hunting wood
clearing and just sharing on whatever
rations that broke Duo could afford one
day after pachita Witnesses dingy cough
up blood both of them are called out on
a mission to take down a devil by their
Old Lake Yakuza dude yet dingier sadly
doped by this old fart who ended up
forming his own contract with his zombie
devil to try and kill dingy after a
short yet absolutely terrifying struggle
to escape from the horde of zombies
dingy and pachita are mortally wounded
by the hundred or so Yakuza turned
zombies after the pier I just left like
garbage and a dumpster their blood from
dingy somehow like through pure manga
Lark managed to flow down and entered
pochita's mouth while going over all of
the happy moments that made up their
friendship he remembers a specific
moment where dingy told him that if he
ever died to then take over his body and
make his dreams come true for him coming
back to reality now Vegeta begins
morphing shape and assumes the role of
dinji's heart merging with his torso
while also repairing his damaged body in
the process back in the dream world and
a complete role reversal UNO card play
but cheetah this time manages to save
dingy but unlike how dingy wanted him to
take over his body and mind he didn't
instead he communicates with him that
he's always loved listening to dingy
talk about his dreams and due to this he
explains that he wants to hear more from
him so he forms a contract with dinji
where he will become his heart and in
return to did you will show him all of
his dreams skipping forward and
throughout this story petite is passed
as the chainsaw man is briefly alluded
to only a few times before the like the
main later arcs during the extremely
long and drawn out battle with the
eternity devil were the main part of the
fourth division is trapped in an almost
separate time and space unable to escape
there then you notices that the devil is
mysteriously afraid of his chainsaws and
also does his best to avoid any kind of
direct confrontation with him instead
asking all of his colleagues to try and
kill the boy yet just to be like super
difficult as well the devil also seems
Overjoyed by the fact that it would be
the one to kill the chainsaw devil I'm
assuming because of this he would in
some way get a huge power up through
killing him obviously he's not a fan of
the Chainsaw man and if he did actually
manage to get the kill all of the fear
that the Devils have towards the change
the devil would probably swap over and
increase the eternity Devil's power even
more plus I'd say he'd be contacted by
the higher up devils like the four
horsemen or maybe even the Primal Devils
if they hate the cheetah just as much as
well anyways after a few days of con
contemplation over what to do and
everyone's favorite cabani trying to
milk dingy with a kitchen knife he
finally does decide to leave the room
and face the eternity Devil head on once
they enter the standoff The Eternity
level screams about how the chainsaw
devil or pachita was indeed alive after
all and that dingy is far weaker than
how pachita was in the past once the
fight reaches its end in that usual like
tatsuki way where dinchi manages to fuel
himself off the enemy's body like some
sort of organic devil reactor that runs
off blood I may know like everyone else
heard the taunts and mentions of the
Chainsaw devil through the eternity
devil and later Ponders to argue why the
eternity devil talks like he knew about
dingy or the devil inside of him
obviously himino herself doesn't fully
understand what dingy is like I don't
think she realizes that dingy has merged
with the devil that is inside of him and
that he currently has a contract with
that devil and that's probably why it's
referred to as dingey's heart
specifically anyway anyway as I've said
because this video is somewhat through
petite's point of view or the stuff that
relates to him directly and his overall
goal with dingy we skip way ahead in
this story to a point throughout the
bomb girl Arc where we meet the first
hardcore fan of the Chainsaw devil and a
personal favorite character of mine
after the events of the previous battle
which was against the katana man so if
you guys want to like catch up on all of
that then you guys can go and check out
my video which will leave a link to down
in the description lucky me tells dng
that she will have to borrow power for a
blood extraction and she sucked on one
too many zombies and is having a Power
Trip currently a new place for the time
being she introduces him to Bane a shark
feign obsessed with dingey's chainsaw
Powers after getting smothered all over
by Bame a hella confused dingy kicks him
back off him and asks makima why in the
world does beam have such devotion
towards him to what she puts on this
like super uh I don't know face and
tells him that maybe it's the
resemblance but before denji can prob
more his cut off a game by this rampant
Bane jumping on him and proclaiming that
he loves chainsaws obviously makimo was
doing her best to lie there and it
actually implied that denji and his
chain Source reminded beam of his God
they chainsaw devil from the Past who he
was obviously a follower of later on we
end up getting a bit of information
relay lighting directly to pachita's
original abilities after the typhoon
devil shows up to help out rezy and
he'll fight against the chainsaw man
Angel realizes that beam also knows
about the original chainsaw devil and
asks him to spit out any information
about him to help dingy better
understand his powers everyone's
favorite shark who's like that's my Lord
chainsaw he's the baddestist explains
that the chainsaw lord of the past was
Ultra fast but when he moves he uses
more than just his feet instead he uses
the chainsaw chains to look into things
to swing between structures like a
chainsaw Spider-Man denji who hears this
plain as the explanation somehow
misinterprets it he thinks that he needs
to use his own powers to move so on the
wildest move and while beam is just
hyping him up and calling him a genius
He commands his shark frame to fully
transform the mountain beam like the
stallion he is dingy screams that he's
got to break baymen with his chain and
ride him like a goddamn horse everyone
then who likes sees this hilariously
reacts to this random change asking if
Bane was correct and being who's
probably just like oh my God my God is
literally on my back until he screams
that this is her correct but anyway
after we get that little bit of
information from beam again we skip
forward in this series to the next point
where we get another mention of
purchaser or specifically something that
affects him more than denji so Judo
Breeze and dinji's fight being caught on
TV the entire world now knows that dingy
or potato more specifically are in Japan
makima absolutely con stingy here uses
the idea that hybrids like dingy are an
extremely valuable asset to specific
countries and that's why they want to
capture him when in all reality it's
most likely that they know about the
true chainsaw man and they're actually
sending assassins to Japan in order to
prevent makima from having the control
she wants over the chainsaw Devil's
heart makima obviously doesn't want them
to steal away but cheetah so she ends up
canceling the trip that they had already
previously planned to instead Force
denji to be put under 24 hour
surveillance this obviously lifts up way
completely disappointed as he was
extremely hyped to get away from Tokyo
and spend some time with mahima because
of the second Tire thing right here he
later ends up getting extremely
depressed and begins wondering who
exactly Vegeta is to begin with and what
is every everyone wants his heart
so next up we're coming forth to like
100 the saddest art throughout the
entire story the one that had been built
up since the very beginning the gun
devil Arc where we get a little bit more
information about the cheetah himself so
if you guys have seen my entire story
video for part one you'll know what
happens to dingy and everyone in Hell
throughout the entire International
assassin's Ark after returning it
extremely affects Powers mentality to
the point where she's unable to do
anything by herself over the fear that
the darkness devil might show up and
kill her at any point to keep you calm
dingy ends up going to the toilet with
her constantly reminding her she's okay
and even bathing with her so that she
doesn't freak out while she's alone this
all culminates in an extremely important
moment for the duo where power offers
dingy some of her blood as an apology
for making him miss out on his trip with
mahima even though they don't realize it
at the time what happens here is
actually so damn important in the
overall story while drinking her blood
then she internally thinks of a cheetah
telling him on how he always thought
naughty things would feel better the
more you know your partner but even
though he knows power extremely well
thus just doesn't feel hot at all he
thinks that it probably isn't that you
should learn anything and everything
there is to know about life but instead
that there are some things you have to
know and some things that are better off
unknown in that moment he casts aside
the idea of ever opening that mysterious
door he always sees inside of his dreams
with Aki obviously being the oldest in
the group over time he began to take on
like this big brother role for everyone
there and with him being unable to
protect his family throughout hell he
became extremely depressed as well about
the possibility of them dying in an
upcoming operation to defeat the gun
devil because of this Aki who's just
trying to keep them safe asks the old
man himself kashiba if it's right if he
quit the operation along with dingy and
power or surprise kishibe as he expected
Aki to be the one most eager for this
event of taking down the gun devil
however after the group later mates
within Minecraft horror herself mummy
makima Ahi ends up getting persuaded to
continue in the operation as either way
she was going to force dingy in power
into going on by simply changing them
from division 4 to division 7 putting
Aki between a rock and a hard sport
later on the future devil who's arky's
new Devil appears after he was called
out too by the way if there is any
confusion over like why Aki has a new
Devil here if Aki was to continue using
the needle weapon that he currently has
he would end up dying as his lifespan
would run out leaving him unable to
complete his own mission of killing the
gun devil plus the fox devil he used
earlier on in this series gapped it and
doesn't want to talk to him anymore due
to it getting damaged in the katana man
battle anyways anyways The Fugitive who
Rises up outside the window sends an
ominous Vision to Aki and States they're
both him and power will end up being
slaughtered by dingy and they completely
and absolutely unavoidable future then
directly after this the devil their
Devil's fear most shall appear
foreshadowing for cheaters or the
chainsaw Devil's return in the future so
I should probably quickly explain what
happens to argue while he's out with
mahima as I get a lot of comments in my
entire story video asking how in the
world are key ended up becoming who he
is later on in the story anyway anyway
any battle with the gun devil as he
approaches Mike humor taking out
thousands and thousands of people Ahi
mahima and Angel all wait by Church in
the open for him once he gets within
shooting distance makima until he shoots
These Chains out of her which pierced
through both Archie and Angel taking
their abilities and adding them to her
Arsenal along with the abilities from
the punishment devil snake devil and
spider devil I'm assuming that this like
didn't instantly kill Aki or Angel and
wasn't a part of the visionar he was
originally given after mahima does some
sort of like craziness making this
portal appear above the gun devil she
then goes ahead and freaking off
screensly freaking do like I actually
really wish we got to see what happened
here as most likely makima went demon
mode and just completely sharted all
over this part of the gun devil then
took him apart and merged him with Aki
turning him into the gun Fame as we know
that's eventually what happens sadly
Judah Aki being merged off screen with
the gun devil the future levels
prediction eventually comes true as
dingy is forced to kill arki in an
attempt to save his one remaining family
member and best friend yet as we all
know that doesn't exactly work out for
dingy who gave up his emotions to makima
and was unable to prevent Powers death
as well to top it off on all of the days
she could have been murked she was
killed in front of her boy on his
birthday while she held his cake in her
hands lift in a crippling depressive
stay after this then she asks makima if
this was all a dream unable to
comprehend why she would even suddenly
do something like that makima then
reveals to him that she wanted to bring
pachita back since the very beginning
however she was unable to do so because
he had to stay sealed away as dingy is
hard due to the promise between them
live with no other choice then she
quickly planned a way to try and break
dingy's well and in turn the promise
between Herman and purchase her makima
explains the promise he made with
pachita was in fact a contract one that
pochita would remain as dingy as hard as
long as dingy fulfilled his dreams of
living a normal life thus makima went
around playing the a normal life for
dinghy making him live with Aki and
Power in the hopes that they would
become like a family and to make their
happiness his new normal then once it
was all set in place she would destroy
the whole thing any form of happiness or
sadness from this point on would be
solely crafted by her and a tactic to
manipulate him even further as she
believes that it's time here toned for
bachita's previous sins finally in a
moment that I'm not even sure if it's
true to this day or not she then reveals
that dingy in fact killed his own father
and manipulates him into believing that
it was a horrible person because of his
patricide and therefore did not deserve
to live his dream of having a normal
life hearing this over and over again it
flashes into dingy's dream world where
he's still a child and sadly because of
that he ends up agreeing with her as he
has now been successfully gaslighted
into believing that he was truly a
horrible person then with that finally
complete makima had successfully broken
dingy's contract with Vegeta leaving the
boy on the couch in a completely
unresponsive State the day after makima
walks alongside a keratonic denge and a
hallway filled with all of Tokyo's
special division for devils and fames
makima then reveals that every single
one of them were followers of the
original chainsaw devil in hell and that
they're all waiting for his resurrection
suddenly being caught off guard though
an unexpected explosion goes off blowing
up this side of the building and joined
the absolute G himself the big teacher
kashiba who had brought an entire
division to kill Marky Murr in
combination with his first move a few of
his other top agents then begin
summoning the hell devil to Earth in an
attempt to trap makima and send her back
to Hell however mahima suddenly enlists
the help of the Chainsaw man by asking
him to save her forcing Vegeta to take
over dengie's catatonic body this is
obviously now due to the fact that the
promise or contract was broken leaving
dinji's body is pretty much a vessel for
pachita and also make any fateful Return
of the original chainsaw man who
technically now also controls dingy's
body but cheetah quickly disposes of the
hell devil literally like cutting him up
within the first panel that he's showing
on and turning him into a couple bits of
Hell shashimi on honestly it's such a
freaking clean panel and I've always
loved going back and checking out like
this panel here where you finally see
the full chainsaw man form for the very
first time anyways anyways a remaining
Asian thing uses himself to revive the
hell devil back telling him to die once
he finishes his job yet for some like
random reason it doesn't attack makima
and instead slaps down up a cheetah as
if he's some sort of bug casting him
directly into hell soon after arriving
there though Vegeta is greeted by hordes
of devils that attack him over and over
again desperately tried to Maul on
however they are simply no match for the
original chainsaw man as he quickly and
effortlessly defeats them all one by one
meanwhile and like Beck and Earth makima
reveals to kashibe the true power of the
Chainsaw man and why people either
worship or fear Him pachita is able to
actually erase a devil's existence and
the concept that they represent by
eating them even now makima who's
probably had some of her friends eaten
by pachita remembers the battles
themselves but the names have started to
fade it's shown that a confused kashiba
doesn't even know know what the Nazi
regime was although the chainsaw man has
already erased things from the world
like AIDS World War II nukes the light
of a specific star that breaks a child's
mind the four conclusions other than
death at the end of life and much much
more have already been erased from
existence by the chainsaw man mummy
makima explains that her goal is that
she's planning to fight him in order to
defeat and control his powers with the
aim of erasing Concepts that she deems
unnecessary for humankind so that she
can create the better world or the world
that she sees first kashibe then asks
her if she's not afraid of losing to
which he responds by saying that she
wouldn't mind being devoured by pachita
as she is a big fan of the Chainsaw man
Vegeta just like he did at the beginning
of the story somehow manages to find a
way out of hell and returns to earth
through a specific door still standing
there with the old man makima continues
to reveal that pachita will always Aid
those who ask for his help but in return
He will also kill them after the deed is
done therefore since she asks for his
Aid Vegeta is coming to destroy her she
warns kashiba stay back and prepares to
engage the cheetah who's now standing
opposite her on another roof but before
she can like literally even move in an
attempt to defend herself Vegeta comes
flying through the window and literally
slices her all up after briefly looking
at kashiba pachita then here's kabini's
call for help from far away and runs to
her location leading Toshiba alone with
makima's body elsewhere at everyone's
favorite burger joint which I can barely
show any of because it's apparently far
too brutal for YouTube kabini is taken
aside by her new boss who chastises her
and slaps her across the face fear
kabini quietly mutters those words she
really wishes she didn't now save me
obviously not realizing the consequences
of this the staff suddenly turned to see
chainsaw man looming over them from here
on for like a little bit the cheetah
kind of like half confused Italy tries
to accomplish a few of his boys watches
themselves he looks at the Restaurant's
menu and remembers an earlier request
from dingy about how he always wanted to
try hamburgers sitting in a nearby table
he attempts to order a hamburger
speaking through a series of Chainsaw
ribs after this freaking hilarious set
of terrible coincidences where capini
manages to drop his meal over and over
again her disbelieving co-workers
watching her begin to believe that this
situation is obviously an elaborate
televised prank yet they will end up
getting joint by pachita figuini's
mistakes but she'd eventually manages to
bite down on his floor Burger but
grimaces it how disgusting it is then in
this same moment he remembers another
past wish of ninjas which was to go on a
date with a girl then without even
asking or thinking he tears kabini away
from a new job to take her out on an ice
cream date stopping at the ice cream van
gentlemen streets it to Paces before
acquiring a pair of ice creams for the
cute couple cabani continues to sob
crying out that the ice cream doesn't
taste of anything which is probably due
to the fact that she's under so much
stress frying her actual taste buds
finally someone who can save the day
then appears and threatens chainsaw man
but JK this was just some thought of
random and he is instantly evacerated by
the chainsaw man espacito then turns
cabani towards the infamous dance
mushroom machine checking it down on the
ground she orders the terrified lady to
dance there could be any comments that
she has no money looking up though she
says that Vegeta had already shred an
ATM to Bert allowing cabani to get some
cash and begin her terrifying world
record run on the dance dance mushroom
machine as this happens Vegeta finally
leaves her to go elsewhere he makes his
way to a random rooftop and will
surveying his surroundings notices that
makima is already nearby she commends
him on him noticing her as she then
begins commanding her allies to emerge
suddenly chains were man stands
surrounded by seven devil Hunters all
commenting on their love for makima and
desire to date her they each pledge
their allegiance to mahima with The
Guitar Man commenting she has saved
their lives over and over again as this
happens makima agrees to the bit which
was a date in return for whoever can
beat the chainsaw man first as makima
stands amongst her group of devil human
hybrids she elaborates on their true
nature they are not humans Devils or
fames but another type of creature that
was erased by the chainsaw Devil's
Powers yet still somehow continues to
exist but shooter though who couldn't
really care less about her just yawns in
response saying this lucky within
command to agents to attack so I've just
got to chill on some aspects of this
fight here so it doesn't get restricted
as our little potato goes absolutely ham
destroying all of these silly old
hybrids but after laying out a few of
the hybrids Vegeta leaps back to the
safety of another building saying this
though the whip hybrid appears and
slashes at him her attacks are like
utterly futile which is probably why she
didn't get her own arc and have little
to no impact rather than slowing his
movement down however resilient blasts
through the building below him and grabs
a hold of the slow chainsaw man carrying
him up into the sky however up in the
sky dingy manages to completely dunk on
reset but still gets stunned in the air
by a spear thrown from the spear hybrid
taking this momentary days to her
Advantage makima points her hand like
some crazy ass finger pistol and says
bang over and over again to blast the
chainsaw man up into the upper
atmosphere of the Earth itself in an
attempt to suffocate him as chainsaw man
is pushed out of the atmosphere fear and
into space he does the most insane
respawn glitch and reaches inside of
himself and rips out a portion of his
own heart he then proceeds to fling it
down towards the ground below and as the
heart of potato begins to burn up upon
re-entry to the atmosphere chainsaw
man's body quickly begins to reform
around it still falling he then does
another Big Brand play and unlike how
dingy uses chains with beam previously
but cheetah uses them correctly
launching all of his chains across the
city rapidly not to makima the whip
flamethrower and spear hybrids then
hoisting them all up into the air they
each Express a moment of shot before
they are too torn apart by pachita's
chainsaws back over with everyone's
favorite cabani her game of dance dance
mushroom is showing coming to a close as
it finally ends she stands there tired
and sweating Atop The Machine before
happily exclaiming that she got a
perfect score yet as she turns her head
to the side her expression turns to one
of worry as she looks over at chainsaw
man who's just chilling on a step nearby
watching her with mahima having also
arrived she goes into state to kabini
and in total she has been killed by the
chainsaw man 26 times and yet she still
questions why it continued to refuse to
hate her confused herself on how she
even got involved in this mess kabini
shows denial but Mucky MC quickly cuts
her off saying that she did indeed have
a major role in the events currently
unfolding and that her fear of Chainsaw
man had grown away Cur this prompts
could be nice to look over at chainsaw
man as blood randomly begins to leak
from his body causing him to collapse
forwards onto the alleyway a television
is then shown in the window of a city
Shop with a news broadcast being
displayed stating that the chainsaw man
had just defeated the gun devil he goes
on to stay that the news of the
gandivals defeat was being met with a
praise and shock across the globe the
following shots then show images of
people thrilled and Overjoyed as they
watched the broadcast on their
televisions with more blood beginning to
pull around the chainsaw man Mucky
mistakes that the humans cheering him on
were eating away at his overall strength
contrasting the power given to him by
all of the Devils who fear her most the
insulating usage 1000 years a large
black spear pushes out from one of those
weird ass Rings makima makes instantly
the faces of cabini and pachita are
shown reacting to the attack their faces
bathed in light as makima launches the
spear directly at cabani in an attempt
to make the chainsaw man defend her but
the hero he is though chainsaw man moves
forward in front of kabini pushing her
away and letting this spear pierced
through his torso causing him to
immediately collapse to the ground
seeing him Gravely wounded Mucky massage
as the nearby crowds continue to cheer
for him his body laying still as the
fear that once surrounded him slowly
begins to fade now remember when I said
that it was super big brain that dinghy
was given some of Howard's blood earlier
on in the series we're going into this
like dream state we find ourselves
inside of Vegeta where he has managed to
find The Last Remnant of powers blood
inside of dinghy turning her head
towards Vegeta a confused power asks who
he is before quickly making the
connection that he was pachita who she'd
been told about through what dingy had
said to him a cheetah smile said a
realization before telling her that he
wanted her to say save dinghy he tells
her that she wasn't truly dead as she
was currently the blood that denji drank
from her before and that if nothing was
done she would soon disappear but she
asks for her to eat his flesh and revive
as a full-fledged devil to what your
girl had the freaking Queen she is
happily obliges so even as much as I've
read the story it still freaking
confuses me at points like someone
please let me know if they know this for
a fact but I think that after power
shoots out of Chainsaw man as the blood
devil dingy was given control back over
his body Papa cheater as after dingy and
power have their final conversation
together and the dumpster where dingy
forms a contract with power to come and
find her again so that they can be
friends again in the future he still has
petite's tail protruding from his chest
anyways enough of that let me know if
you guys know if I was correct there or
not down in the comment section below
anyways a bunch of stuff with dingy goes
down in between him finally getting
control back of his body and making it
to the fateful day at the graveyard with
dinji and mahima have their final battle
obviously the majority of this fight
here happens with like Genji's point of
view so I'll only bring up the things
that relate to Vegeta directly but
something I do want to point out that is
super interesting is that three crows at
the very beginning of this fight or like
before the battle even begins a showing
of Racine on a few Graves nearby before
flying up into the sky this here alludes
to the like other three foes and The
Four Horsemen that our boy is going to
have the defeat in the near future it
could be more into this final battle
where makima like absolutely dunks on
dingshi it really isn't even a fight at
this point it's just kind of a bait down
she takes a hold of dingy's wounded
corpse from the handle atop his head
then proceeds to tear up a cheetah with
her right arm but I can't I'll show you
guys that here because YouTube is
freaking crazy with chainsaw man and
taking down people who show this panel
like I'm not trying to bring light to
the savageness of the story or
sensationalize it I'm trying to bring
light to the absolutely brilliant
writing that is tatsuki Fujimoto and how
he has crafted his story so well from
like this start to the end of her anyway
I can't do much about this just smash
that like button and try and get this
video to like 5 to 10K likes or
something so that I know you guys want
more of this series where I go over like
individual characters themselves and
they are like life story from throughout
chainsaw man anyways as she slowly pulls
pachita from his body she tells dinghy
that even when she used nothing but her
bare fists he still lost to her and that
he was not nearly as strong as chainsaw
man she asked how she could possibly get
him to completely give up on living and
how she could ever possibly get chainsaw
man back from him then she responds by
not talking and instead spitting on her
face causing makima to get angry and
rage out responding by telling him that
chainsaw men did not ever spit in
people's faces no he was Far Far
different gentleman obviously did not
wear clothes or even speak and that he
only made him miss out of everything
that he did she says that even with all
of Genji's ignorance he was still chosen
as chainsaw man which puzzles her but
now since he was standing between the
two of them he must die after mahima for
some like bizarre reason think she's
like managed to kill the protag of this
entire Series this Archie wannabe lights
up a smoke before literally coughing her
own lungs out quickly she puts out the
full smoke so it doesn't light up fire
and realizes that she can't handle the
heat and instead picks up pochita
telling him that now it's the second
time she had ever defeated him she
explains that he now belongs to her and
that they are going to be together
forever that they Lots together sleep
together and live a happy life together
forever several feet behind makima
though dingy who isn't actually dead
slowly stands up from amongst a pile of
corpses now wearing an oversized Public
Safety uniform he quietly walks over to
makima and as soon as she starts to
notice him he pulls out a damn chainsaw
and slices her down the chest confused
and shocked makima gasps as she begins
to collapse and Falls to her knees
tenshi then in a complete raw reversal
from before now stands directly above
her reaching down dingy picks up his boy
pachita then exclaims that he'll be
taking him back and says that what he
did now was extremely dangerous and that
he'd used up all of the blood power had
given to him from their contract hence
while like I mentioned this stuff that
happened in the dumpster earlier
otherwise it wouldn't have made sense I
didn't mention it anyway mahima now in a
spot that she possibly expected to be in
at some point asks how danger was even
alive twitch also remember how potato
ripped out a portion of his heart and
then threw it back to the ground when he
was like almost blasted into space well
that was who makuma was actually
fighting the entire time and then she
just vaguely remembered how to fight
lopachita so yeah so with the power
chainsaw running amok inside of makima
she was caught off guard and unable to
move being stuck there in that one
location with the blood constantly like
tearing her up from the inside some
absolutely mental stuff happens directly
after this that involves a van one full
fridge of like probably delectable meat
and dingy stomach but there is one final
huge moment in this series with a cute
little pachita makes another appearance
so skipping forward to after we meet the
new control devil because for those
unsure Duda dingy munching back makima
like I just literally alluded to and the
way that he did it didn't result in her
being erased from existence but instead
it was almost a way to get around her
uncanny contractor for the Japanese
prime minister now back home and after
falling asleep in bed with a new control
devil nayuta dingy begins to dream where
the dogs sleeping with him now being
replaced by petite her within this dream
a young dingy opens his eyes and finds
himself holding pachita as the toaster
within the shed they used to live in
Vegeta tells dingy that his dream was to
be hugged by someone but his strength
always made it hard for anyone to want
to hug him and that's probably why like
after he ended up saving someone he
ended up also killing them because he
probably need to hug them and murked
them in the exact same moment which is
kind of sad when you think about it
Vegeta realizes that it sounded crazy
but ensures dingy that he wasn't lying
he then thanked stingy for finally
making his dream come true after this he
asked stingy if he could do one more
thing and fulfill the control Devil's
dream as well as she's always dreamed of
building an equal relationship with
other people the control devil had
always dreamed a verse but couldn't seem
to accomplish it because she only knew
how to form relationships through Power
or fear and because of that she grew
yearning for something like a family
over time Vegeta tells dingy that now he
wanted him to make their dream come true
for neuter to which dinji asked for
cheetah how he was supposed to do there
and a lovable little doggo tells him to
give her lots and lots of hugs
so that there officially brings us to
the very end of waters but cheater's
life everything that is kind of given to
us that relates to him specifically
throughout part one of the story
obviously if you guys have enjoyed this
video and want to watch more stuff just
like this then let me know who you want
me to go over in the future if it'd be
like Aki or say mahima's full life
throughout the story then I'll go and
cover that because at least you know we
have everything from their life
specifically so far in this story as
well that I can go over in huge detail
including like Aki's background from
when he was a childhood which is
extremely extremely important and the
overall narrative with him and dingy and
them like becoming Brothers in a sort of
way absolutely love like Howard ends up
fleshing out between the two of them and
the final like battle that ends up going
down sorry to spoil any of you anime
only that are here but you know it's an
absolutely amazing battle that sadly
results in the death of his brother Aki
so if you guys want me to go over there
then let me know down in the comment
section below and I'll be sure to do
that in the future obviously though if
you are new around here I want to watch
more stuff just like this then make sure
you hit that subscribe button and also
be sure to leave a like on the video as
helps out with pushing my content to a
bunch of new amazing people and if you
want earlier access to my videos like
two days before they go live on YouTube
then be sure to check out my patreon
down on the link below which I will
leave there for all of you but for now
it's been your professional degenerate
diavolo and I will see you all in a bit
bye